foreign
[Music]
gifts to her job and they said she
called off today
hmm no she did no she I've been
screaming no she did it no she didn't
she's called off today I'm there with
teddies flowers that works with who is
she with
who is she with ah just come up I'm
afraid yeah yeah she's lost she's off
today bro you should know that no you're
a man no doesn't she live with you yeah
see they see that it's big because I
already know that co-worker knows she's
cheating on me so they're you're all
playing a game and I don't like it
because someone's gonna get bold because
I know soon as you turn your back to go
back in the office it's one of these
ones it's shoulders go in because you're
giggling yeah Vex nah babes you're still
cute just seeing them little toilet
paper pieces stuck from the back
surprised me
yeah yeah it's not her fault but yeah
it's still cute but I've seen that
before you know what the busting is is
when it's rolled up like that
it must have stroked all the way up
because it's rolled thin oh my and it
does it's just you just wanna
it's yucky y'all homie you spank the bat
yeah
it's yucky food
oh my God nothing we can do about it but
it's yucky you want just like Binky it
just to clear off I think I flicked it
one time no you never yeah she would
have been like [__] no
um
accuracy now what was I doing I think I
was no I was stinks in I was gonna go
sting so I went for the rub oh yeah yeah
I went for the rock because she was
laying on her front yeah obviously yeah
I was it was a massage thing so I was on
a Friday yeah yeah yeah yeah
and you're getting your box yeah
it's one of them ones you're struggling
but you also don't want her to notice
yourself no but she knows yeah
you're too excited you can't control
your breathing
hahaha
ah because you can't have a look back
and see what you're doing you're too
silent as a rock you're too solid and
you're dead and you're just trying to
get that yeah and the consistency of the
rubber is all over the place you're
distracted
I know she's rolling her eyes down there
so anyway I was massage you to sing [__]
that's pretty funny boxes are coming up
I go down yeah the slopes of her back
spread the cheeks yeah yeah and I see
the little little tissue thing and I was
like yuck bro damn but obviously I'm
here oh yeah yeah yeah you know so I
went back up and I was spreading the
cheeks and I think one time I spread it
and I think I went for like a oh yeah
flicked flicked it off part of the play
yeah we're just playing around yeah yeah
yeah Daddy's just playing around a
little bit oh my goodness that's sweet
we've every man has been there it's the
funniest thing it literally is and that
first slide is sentence there's nothing
like it there's nothing like it you just
sit into it nah bro there's not an
entrance like it that's a Mayweather
entrance oh oh
my god oh this might be one of the
funniest episodes [__] I'm dying bro
HIV
I haven't seen him
focused he got like two promotions in a
little over a year might be the move for
real
jokes right I've got I've got a second
one actually hit me this one's sweet at
me
when I left when I let my ex carry a 40
pack of water up two flights of stairs
that's when I knew I didn't love her
anymore
quote treats his own tweet she sat it
down and took a break on the landing I
just walked around her no bam a 40 pack
took a break I just walked around her
carry it yeah you don't love her carry
it wow treacherous
I got an interview tomorrow she said my
resume was impressive I need to find it
so I could I know what lies I told these
people bro I used to have a different CV
for every job I applied for and that
doesn't surprise me is there a
difference between every single job it
was a surprise copy that they're [__]
what they're what they're looking for
yeah paste it in my CV
oh it's jokes
being kissed in your sleep is like the
purest form of love reply unless you're
home alone reply or in jail
I couldn't have next man kiss me to
sleep
in your sleep not even to sleep in
yourself in Ben
no
no I'm doing a longer straight Duppy in
somewhere yeah yeah I have to do a
longer stretch
um yeah bro this is giving uh was it not
in hell
yeah I'm just a hot girl standing in
front of a poorly dressed objectively
unattractive guy telling him it's fine
if he doesn't want a relationship but
could he maybe text me more consistently
he said no
oh my God
it's okay if you don't want to be my man
but can we up the communication a little
bit I don't like being aired for four
hours he said nah nah nah that sounds
like hassle yeah just know I'm not on it
New York isn't real
just just saw two women kissing on the
crowded train and a guy looked at him
and said you guys can't do that at home
he got weird looks and he got weird
looks and so you felt the need to
clarify I'm not a homophobic I'm just a
hater
I'm just jealous I'm jealous I mean yeah
[__]
it's a tweet and a quote yeah the thing
is I might have said this one before but
I don't remember but it's hilarious
guys who speaks Spanish are so
attractive to me
quote tweet underlay underlay Mommy
I couldn't even get out bro let's go
laughs
that is jokes guys he's speaking Spanish
and the way he wrote it he wrote it he
spelled it phonetically so I knew
exactly
what's popping tonight
funny
a restaurant owner in Barcelona threw
out PK and his girlfriend because of his
love for Shakira quote sweet this is how
I want people to act when I say I don't
like someone
swear stupid bro this is the last one
hello Cool J has Paul has decided to
pull the plug on his latest Studio
effort
which would have been his first album in
10 years because he feels as if it
wasn't worthy of being released quote
tweet got a lot of respect for a man who
knows that his work is mid
that's tough
that's tough sailors say less all right
go out take that image yeah I couldn't
read that that's tough oh yeah I
couldn't
but yeah
[Music]